the Java back-end part of the app is
independent of the front end or the UI
in this case the back end defines
endpoint functions and the UI calls
those functions so we're going to start
our explanation of the code by looking
at the definition of the endpoint
functions so I've opened up hello world
endpoints it's in this is the package
and then we've imported the classes that
we need from the SPI dot config package
the SPI basically means endpoints so
here are the imports that we need to use
endpoints now here at the top of the
file it says at API net and its name
equals hello world endpoints version
equals v1 this is where we're saying hey
this file contains endpoint functions as
the description it's pretty obvious and
then the client IDs specify which
clients are allowed to use these
endpoint functions here we've specified
constants top web client ID but actually
for now we don't really care which
client uses us but this one is important
that API Explorer
so we've specified that the API Explorer
client ID is allowed to use our endpoint
functions and if we look at constants
Java see here the web client ID we
didn't really set it but here we did set
the API Explorer client ID we get this
from constant API underscore Explorer
and score client ID and we get this from
the SPI dot constant package so if you
want API Explorer to be able to access
your back-end functions you do need to
enable the client ID to use API Explorer
okay so back here in hello world
endpoints we've defined just a couple
different endpoints are very very simple
the first method is say hello and we've
declared it as an app or an app API
method by default every method inside a
file that's been declared as a NAT API
is exposed through endpoints but you can
set the name a few on and the path and
then the method so here the say hello
method simply returns a new instance of
the hello class object we'll look at
that in just a second and then the next
method say
hello by name it takes an argument name
and we've declared it must be named the
argument must be named name and we
return a new instance of the hello class
created with the name string that's all
these methods do basically they say
hello and they say hello by name so both
of these methods return an instance of
hello class so let's quickly take a look
at hello class and you see this is a
really simple class doesn't import
anything it's just a POJO plain old java
object it has one field message has a
default constructor and it has a
constructor that takes the name and
generates a message based on the name
and sets the message that's all it does
now the reason we need this class is
because endpoint functions can't return
string objects they have to return
objects with seals otherwise we could
probably just define our endpoint
functions to return a string of the
message but since we need a real object
we're using hello class for it okay now
I'm going to run my app and I'm going to
run it on the dev server on localhost so
this time since I've already got the
configuration the run configuration set
up I just go to run as and then I choose
maven build I choose the configuration
that I set up earlier and then I choose
ok now it's going to run it on localhost
again you can go to localhost and see
your app see the home page for your app
but actually I don't want to do that
right now
I want to go straight to the API
Explorer to get there you just add a
slash underscore aah slash API flash
explorer localhost colon 8080 slash an
underscore aah slash API slash Explorer
so you see this when you go to the API
Explorer you can click on services to
show the services and then you can click
on the available API to drill down to
see what functions are available and we
have say hello and we have say hello by
name and if you recall these are the two
functions that were defined in hello
world endpoints Java and you can
actually exit
these functions right here in the API
Explorer so we click say hello we say
execute and then you scroll down you'll
see the request which shows the requests
that got sent and you see the response
and you see our responses messages hello
world kind of what we expected now let's
go up and try the next one say hello by
name now see here it says name remember
how we had app named in our API well
this is going to show the name here bit
confusing because we have app named name
but this is the named argument right
here so let's enter a name and then
we'll execute it and again here's the
request but here's the response hello
Lauren
it took the name that we supplied okay
cool
so now you know how to use the API
Explorer